( Amy )
Thank you for
coming over.
I've never
seen him this depressed.
You know, I think it
hits men especially hard
when they're unemployed.
Yeah, but even
worse than that
is the new therapy
that he's on.
Hey, Mark.
Oh, hey, Colleen.
You need help, you want me
to get you something?
No, I don't need help,
I'm not five.
Where's my
lucky glass?
It's next to
the books.
I'm at the books.
I see it right
in front of you.
Oh, I got it,
it was at the books.
Why is he skipping?
That's the therapy.
The doctor told him
to skip
as a way to
trick himself
into feeling happier.
Yeah, you know, I think
I saw something about this
on that show
"The Doctors."
I only saw a little bit
because the show's
unwatchable.
Hey, babe, I'm sorry I, like,
was curt with you,
but I'm feeling
a little better.
I think this is starting
to work.
I'm starting to,
like, feel it.
Great,
that's great, babe.
Hey, I'm gonna go upstairs
and watch some of
my karate movies.
Okay.
Bye, Colleen.
♪
Ho-ho, he got it.
Whoo!
Close.
That guy's
got my number today, huh?
Yeah.
Why don't
you try running?
Here.
He's fast
like a cheetah.
Babe, babe!
I'll get that later.
♪♪
No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, let me...
Yes.
Nothing's
too good for my princess.
Now you eat up.
( whispering )
Stop skipping.
Babe, I feel, like,
lately
things have been
a little off with us.
Mainly you.
Mainly me.
So I, um, talked
to my psychiatrist
and he wrote you this
prescription.
Don't be mad.
The Electric Slide?
♪ You can do it ♪
Look, are you gonna stop
skipping anytime soon?
I don't know.
Are you ever gonna try
The Electric Slide?
No.
Why can't you be
happy for me?
Look, I don't think
I can do this any more.
Oh, my God!
I got it,
I'll get it
No, Mark,
it's too dangerous!
♪
( video game sounds beeping )
( girls singing quietly )
( girl )
Whoo!
Oh, yeah!
Come on, man!
Whoo!
You the man!
Thank you.
Bye.
( grunting )
( groaning )
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
I love you.
I love you, I love you.
I'm so sorry.
No, I love you,
I'm sorry.
I've been such
a jerk-- I love you.
I'm gonna throw out all
my Aerosmith T-shirts and--
No, I've never liked those
shirts but I support you.
You never have to talk
to my mother again.
I already found a way to
kind of stop talking to her.
I love you so much.
I love you too.
Baby--
I'm sorry to
interrupt, folks.
That was the bravest
goddamn thing
I have ever seen
in my goddamn life.
Goddamn.
Call me?
We could use a guy
like you on the force.
Screw it.
You got the job.
( gasping )
Oh, my gosh!
This is the best day
of my life.
Our life.
♪
Hey, you learned
The Electric Slide.
Uh, wait, it's gonna
take me a second.
Okay.
You can just...
Come back?
Yeah, let's head it back.
Ooh.
♪
Maybe we should
just take a cab.
Yeah, do you mind
if we take a cab?
Yeah.
I'm just so tired.
I'm into this
but I'm just tired.
No, no, no,
it's a good idea.